[Music]
hey what's up guys and kid Bhd here back
with the one plus seven pro arguably the
phone of the year so far and i'm not the
only one who thinks that so usually when
a phone first comes out i get to do an
impressions video of what i first think
about it when it gets released and we
talk about it in the comments for a
little bit and we figure out what people
are mostly curious about for the full
review and then i do a review but of
course with the 1 plus 7 pro that wasn't
the case i had just a couple weeks to
use it and then went straight into a
full review so now after that there's
been a couple things have bubbled up and
there's some interesting tidbits that
were left out that weren't in the full
review or updates to it that i still
think are pretty interesting so this
video is all the little things you might
still not know about the 1 plus 7 pro
even after the review and some
clarification on things that were in it
so first about being waterproof so the 1
plus 7 pro isn't technically IP
certified but they have also made this
point to pretty much tell everyone their
phones are safe being splashed on dave
CD did his entire review video with the
phone totally under water in a bowl next
to him and took it out at the end and it
was fine
basically getting a phone officially IP
certified means adding all the rubber
and the seals internally and then going
through independent testing that cost
extra money so oneplus has made it a
point to still go through the same
diligence to add all the rubber and the
seals but not pay for the independent
testing and just pass along those
savings to us i could only assume that
they've done some sort of internal
testing on their own which gives them
this confidence that they can tell
people you can splash water on it or go
out on the rain i don't know how much
per unit this actually saved us buyers
i've heard numbers ranging from 10 bucks
to 30 bucks per unit which sounds like a
lot to me but bottom line is I'm ok with
it as long as the third-party testing
we're now seeing by people like Dave
seems to show this will hold up fine and
then for those wondering about RAM since
there are a couple different specs you
can get of the 7 Pro with either 6 8 or
12 gigs of ram so you can check out this
page in oxygen OS where it shows my
average ram usage with my medium to
heavy use I'm averaging around 5 gigs of
memory used so technically I'd be fine
with 6
a ram but I think I'd go ahead and
upgrade to eight just to be safe
one plus only charges thirty extra
dollars to do that so $6.99 and you give
yourself a little Headroom the twelve
gigs of ram is a bit more about future
proofing and taking advantage of one
pluses ram boost feature where it
preloads some parts of apps into the ram
so it can open them even faster but
that's you know bordering on overkill I
love it but you'll only really notice it
at the crazy high end of using the phone
and then there's still no G cam app or
Google cam report for the one plus seven
Pro yet still cross my fingers for it
side note I don't know how exactly it's
gonna work with multiple cameras since
all of Google's phones only have one
camera could be interesting to see what
that ends up looking like anyway the
stock camera app also has some things to
note number one in the settings you can
turn on or off ultra wide-angle
correction by default it's on and I
think most people will like it this way
it minimizes distortion around the edges
but if you turn it off this Nets you a
bit of a more distorted GoPro like look
that you might be into so if you want to
turn that off the choice is yours then
too you can actually choose which photo
modes show up in the slider along the
bottom and in what order so if you take
a lot of nightscape shots or if you use
Pro Mode a lot you can just move those
up to be a slide away all the time or
remove the ones you don't use so that's
a nice customization that actually wish
stock Android had or iPhones head and
then you cannot record video from the
ultra wide camera you can from the
regular camera or even the telephoto but
not from the ultra wide like LG and
Huawei let you that is disappointing to
me I asked oneplus about it they told me
officially they do not have plans to
support video from the wide-angle camera
that's what they said okay another note
people were asking a lot about the speed
of the retracting selfie camera so
what's cool is if this little pop-up
selfie camera is out and the phone
detects some sort of freefall it
automatically retracts into the phone so
in case it lands somewhere around there
it'll prevent damage that's smart so i
roughly timed how long it takes the
motor to open and close since it's not
instant and it seems to take somewhere
around half a second to actually go from
fully out to retracted a freefall in
that time is somewhere around 1.2 meters
or 4 feet for any object including this
phone so that means if you're at like
selfie normal height and you drop it
from 5 feet it will
be fully retracted by the time it hits
the ground but if you're just dropping
it on a counter or just like from pocket
height and it's not quite four feet
there's a chance it will still actually
not be done retracting by the time it
hits the ground but honestly I still
think half way retracted is still better
than fully exposed if it happens to land
on it so I still think this feature is
useful and a lot of cool videos came out
of it too alright so there's some other
feature is an oxygen OS that I'd want to
see in some other skins so this applies
to more than just the 1 plus 7 Pro but a
bunch of one-plus phones that includes
the ability to change the accent color
of the entire OS to literally any color
you want that's pretty dope
being able to hide any of the icons up
in the top and the status bar if you
don't want them to be there I mentioned
that in the full review I still love
that I can do that and then also this
little animation for stuff in the quick
settings like turning on and off
airplane mode it's a really nice subtle
touch a couple other roms also do this
and then since it's such a big phone the
ability to swipe down anywhere and get
notifications or swipe up anywhere in
the launcher to get the app drawer you
can do this with third-party launchers
but of course being in a stock launcher
that's convenient too I've seen this
before and I'm happy to have it here on
such a big phone and then I've got some
clarifications from the full review so
first on refresh rate I think I
mentioned in the full review that it was
locked at 90 Hertz technically
technically this is actually already
variable refresh rate so the 1 plus 7
Pro display is always locked at 90 Hertz
unless you are watching a video in the
camera app or on a phone call in which
case it'll go down to 60 Hertz so that's
what I heard from one plus officially
those are the times it goes down so that
makes sense you don't need 90 Hertz on a
phone call or even when you're watching
a 30fps video or in the camera app where
you're not doing 90 fps those are the
good times for it to throttle down but
even still if you're just on the home
screen or if you're just sitting reading
an article and not moving the screen too
much it's still refresh rate locked at
90 Hertz so that's still gonna be eating
through some battery life so it says
sort of a middle-level compromise and
there's still a possibility of a
software update coming to improve those
times where it can be refreshed variably
more often and then speaking of battery
a lot of people didn't like my
assessment of the four to four and a
half hours of screen on time I was
getting on the oneplus 7 pro
you know some other reviewers are
getting 6-7 hours but that screen on
time metric that I used it's extremely
relative and specific to your usage
style you can't really just directly
compare one person's screen on time to
another person's screen on time because
these people don't use the same apps or
the same accessories or the same
brightness even I haven't or ously had a
very taxing way of using my phones you
know high brightness all the time
bluetooth always on NFC oh is on a lot
of GPS navigation multitasking often so
you can compare my four and a half hours
of screen on time on this phone with my
screen on time across other devices that
used the same way which will range
between like three hours on the worst
ones to the six to seven hours of the
chimp the p30 pro so that being said the
battery life on my one plus seven pro
it's actually slowly slowly gotten more
consistent and slightly better over the
weeks I've used it but it's still not
amazing since I leave ninety Hertz on
and it's a 1440p display max brightness
but I haven't gotten past five hours of
screen on time on a day just quite yet
it's not terrible by any means but you
know fast charging usually saves the day
for me most of the time and then lastly
there is a one plus seven coming it's
just not coming to the US so there's a
one plus seven pro we all know this
starts at six sixty nine the one plus
seven will be you know essentially a
revised version of the one plus sixty
the teardrop notch a 1080p AMOLED 60
Hertz but just with internal specs
bumped up snapdragon a 55 that type of
thing I kind of still wish that was
coming to the u.s. at a lower price that
would have been pretty exciting but I
also pulley understand oneplus is
pricing strategy here maybe I'll try to
get my hands on the standard one plus
seven anyway maybe let me know in the
comments if that's something you'd be
into honestly though the price of the
oneplus 7 pro is still kind of amazing
though like if you imagine this from any
other company imagine for a second
Samsung comes out with a special edition
Galaxy S 10 plus right now some new
colorway or something and they give it a
no hole punch at 90 Hertz display and 12
gigs of ram like you could easily see
that phone being a thousand plus dollars
right but because it's one plus we had a
certain set of expectations for it
and I still would say it delivered
anyway I hope this video clears
many questions people had about the 1
plus 7 Pro or gives you some extra
information I'll leave the link to the
full review below again if you're
interested in watching that but this has
been distracting me so much from pixel
3a and this new zenfone that came out
with the swiveling screen and everything
so videos on those are now upcoming
thanks to this one being done alright
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one peace